ya hemos hablado del proceso de ir del
adn verdad comenzando con adn para ir
creando rn a mensajero verdad para ir
creando rn a mensajero y hemos llamado a
este proceso como transcripción verdad y
esto ocurre justamente en el núcleo de
la célula todo esto ocurre en el núcleo
de la célula y luego éste rn a mensajero
digamos hacer su camino hacia fuera del
núcleo verdad y se une a un ribosoma
verdad entonces una vez que se ha unido
a un ribosoma verdad entonces se traduce
en una proteína muy bien entonces este
rn a mensajero se traduce en una
proteína y entonces podríamos decir que
todo este procedimiento todo este
proceso más bien se lleva a cabo en el
ribosoma en un ribosoma muy bien
y con este digamos panorama muy amplio
verdad ahora vamos a pensar un poquito
más cómo es que esto ocurre verdad o
cómo es la estructura de todas las cosas
en donde todo este procedimiento ocurre
muy bien así que digamos vamos a dibujar
es el núcleo muy bien vamos a empezar
digamos pintando el núcleo y digamos en
vez de dibujar el núcleo como una sola
línea voy a hacer dos líneas verdad
vamos a dibujar estas dos líneas que
entonces ahí teníamos la primera y ahora
vamos a pintar la segunda línea verdad y
estamos pintando dos líneas porque de
hecho es una membrana formaba formada
por dos capas bill y picas verdad así
que la primera sería esta capa que
tenemos aquí y tenemos otra capa be
lipídica muy bien y por supuesto no
estoy dibujando lo todo en una escala
adecuada simplemente lo estoy dibujando
de esta forma para que puedas tener una
mejor noción de cómo son
cosas muy bien digamos si si nos
acercamos mucho digamos si hiciéramos un
acercamiento en cada una de estas líneas
verdad vamos a hacer un cuadradito en
donde podamos ver el acercamiento a cada
una de estas líneas en realidad lo que
veríamos es una capa be lipídica verdad
aquí tendríamos una capa be lipídica
esto verdad por supuesto los círculos
verdad serían como nuestra terminación
hidrofílica mientras que las líneas
serían las terminaciones hidrofóbicas
verdad y ésta sería nuestra capability
dick así que cada una de estas líneas
que he dibujado es una capability dica y
bien ya tenemos toda esta transcripción
digamos andando verdad tenemos el adn
vamos a poner adn digamos que aquí
tenemos todo el adn que está
completamente digamos hecho un revoltijo
verdad en forma de cromatina dentro del
núcleo ahora la pregunta es cómo le hace
digamos el adn para digamos hacerse de
su camino hacia fuera de esta capa
bilibid y acá verdad y la forma en la
que lo hace es a través de los poros
nucleares verdad así que un poro nuclear
esencialmente es un túnel vamos a
dibujar
este túnel entonces esto sería
esencialmente digamos un poro nuclear y
de hecho hay miles de este tipo de
túneles verdad hay miles de este tipo de
túneles en la membrana nuclear verdad
de hecho el túnel está hecho de un
montón de proteínas justamente que hemos
puesto aquí en amarillo verdad
digamos puedes pensar que esto es como
una sección transversal verdad de lo que
es la membrana verdad pero bueno podrías
imaginarte muy bien digamos si lo ves en
tres dimensiones verdad podrías
imaginarte un túnel verdad y este túnel
por supuesto está hecho de proteínas
verdad y ahora bien el rn ha mensajero
puede hacerse en su camino a través de
esta membrana verdad digamos pintemos
aquí el rn a mensajero verdad muy bien y
entonces puede unirse eventualmente a un
ribosoma que se encuentre libre vamos a
pintar aquí un ribosoma que se encuentre
y después puede digamos traducirse en
una proteína muy bien entonces podríamos
pintar aquí ya la proteína traducida
verdad pero por supuesto esta no es
digamos la imagen completa de qué es lo
que ocurre porque cuando traducimos
digamos el rn a mensajero utilizando un
ribosoma libre esto es esencialmente
para las proteínas que son utilizadas
dentro de la célula así que vamos a
dibujar digamos toda la célula completa
por aquí que vamos a pintar su frontera
que entonces más o menos
era así muy bien entonces todo esto que
tenemos aquí es nuestra celular ok y
esencialmente este digamos todo este
fluido que se encuentra entre el núcleo
y digamos con esta frontera es lo que
conocemos como el sito sol muy bien este
será el sito sol no no
no deberías confundirte con el término
también de citoplasma esencialmente el
citó sol es el fluido que se encuentra
entre los organelos del de la célula
verdad y el citoplasma es todo aquello
que está dentro de la célula y fuera del
núcleo así que él citó sol y los
organelos y digamos todo todo lo que
tienen dentro los organelos es el
citoplasma verdad el citoplasma es todo
lo que está dentro de la célula pero
fuera del núcleo y él citó sol
simplemente es el fluido entre los
organelos bueno como sea el el ribosoma
libre que habíamos pintado aquí verdad
la traducción que se llevó a cabo de
esta proteína es buena para esas
proteínas que son utilizadas dentro de
la misma célula verdad estas estas
proteínas pueden flotar verdad a través
del sito sol y pueden ser utilizados en
la forma que sea apropiada pero la
pregunta podría ser cómo obtenemos
proteínas hacia digamos el exterior de
la célula o incluso por ejemplo en la
membrana celular ok en digamos en el
interior de la membrana celular de hecho
vamos a pensar a estas proteínas digamos
como encajadas dentro de la membrana
celular verdad nosotros sabemos que las
células se comunican de muchísimas
formas distintas verdad y que de hecho
producen proteínas para otras células o
pueden ser utilizadas en el torrente
sanguíneo o no se puede puede haber
muchas posibilidades entonces es en este
tipo de detalles en los que nos vamos a
enfocar en este vídeo muy bien así que
fijémonos primero en esta región que
tenemos aquí
digamos que es en esta región que está
entre estas dos capas celulares este por
supuesto se le conoce como el espacio
peri nuclear verdad este es el espacio
entre las dos membranas así que vamos a
etiquetar esto esta de aquí es la
membrana interna verdad la membrana
nuclear interna mientras que esta que
tenemos aquí es la membrana nuclear
externa y de hecho podríamos continuar
esta membrana externa más o menos
digamos siguiendo como como todos estos
dobleces y digamos toda la todas estas
protuberancias verdad más o menos de
esta forma
no sé estoy tratando de hacer un muy
buen dibujo de lo que quiero explicar y
más o menos esta continuación de
protuberancias y dobleces verdad se le
considera como un orgánulo separado
verdad y esto justamente que tenemos
aquí es lo que conocemos como el
retículo endoplasmático en este es el
retículo endoplasmático endoplasmático
que yo siempre he creído que sería un
nombre ideal para crear una banda quizás
de rock pero bueno el retículo
endoplasmático es digamos la clave para
empezar a producir y que después podamos
empaquetar digamos las proteínas que ya
sea que se encajan en la membrana
celular o son utilizadas en el exterior
de la célula y la pregunta es cómo es
que esto ocurre
bueno el retículo endoplasmático tiene
esencialmente dos regiones aunque y
vamos a distinguir dos regiones del
retículo endoplasmático tiene por
supuesto el retículo endoplasmático
rugoso verdad y éste tiene un montón de
ribosomas así que
vamos a poner estos ribosomas por aquí
que vamos a poner varios ribosomas que
corresponden digamos a la zona del
retículo endoplasmático rugoso ok
estos ribosomas digamos están unidos a
la membrana del retículo endoplasmático
y digamos esta región en donde tenemos
estos ribosomas es lo que conocemos como
el retículo endoplasmático de hecho
vamos a vamos a abreviar lo así solo
como el retículo endoplasmático rugoso
muy bien así que vamos simplemente a
llamarle r rugoso ok entonces aquí
tenemos esa región y por supuesto vamos
a tener otra región que conocemos como
el retículo endoplasmático liso muy bien
y digamos el papel que juega en la
síntesis de proteínas digamos o al menos
es el papel que tiene para hacer que las
proteínas comiencen a estar listas para
estar fuera de las células verdes por
ejemplo si nosotros aquí teníamos
nuestro
en el mensajero verdad que teníamos con
color verde entonces una vez que
encuentra digamos a un ribosoma libre
entonces este ritmo y este ribosoma
después puede moverse hacia el retículo
endoplasmático durante la traducción
verdad y entonces a medida que la
proteína está siendo traducida verdad de
hecho puede ser que no sea traducida
dentro del cito sol sino que va a ser
traducida en el digamos del del otro
lado del retículo endoplasmático rugoso
verdad podríamos decir en el interior de
verdad en el lumen del retículo
endoplasmático rugoso así que vamos a
hacer vamos a hacer un dibujito de esto
verdad aquí teníamos nuestro nuestras
proteínas verdad o más bien perdón no
era la proteína sino el rn a mensajero
que después se tradujo en proteínas y
quedan digamos en el interior del
retículo endoplasmático verdad vamos a
hacerlo un poco más grande
digamos que aquí tenemos
membrana del retículo endoplasmático
nuestra membrana y digamos que tenemos
aquí unido nuestro ribosoma verdad ahí
está nuestro ribosomas vamos a pensar
que aquí tenemos nuestro rn a mensajero
verdad que de hecho va en esta dirección
y por supuesto está digamos membrana es
sólo una capability dica que tenemos
verdad de hecho lo que veríamos es algo
así
algo así esta es una capa vil y pica
verdad es exactamente como lo hemos
estado pintando en otras ocasiones
verdad aquí tenemos de hecho esta es una
continuación de la membrana nuclear
exterior verdad entonces ahí tenemos
nuestra continuación verdad y digamos en
algún momento verdad en el proceso de la
traducción la proteína puede ser
escupido hacia adentro digamos al ser
escupido hacia el interior del retículo
endoplasmático verdad entonces aquí
estarán haciendo
el liberada esta proteína en el interior
verdad digamos en el lumen del retículo
endoplasmático y si aquí está el
interior quiere decir que acá nos
encontramos en el exterior verdad este
sería el exterior digamos en el cito sol
verdad podríamos decir que es el
exterior en el cito sol que es lo que
ocurre ahora bueno en algún momento
puede digamos brotar hacia afuera verdad
así que digamos que vamos digamos que
tomemos acá verdad aquí teníamos nuestra
proteína liberada en el interior digamos
del retículo endoplasmático verdad y
entonces y éste eventualmente puede
brotar hacia afuera verdad y de hecho lo
hace por ejemplo en el retículo
endoplasmático liso que por cierto tiene
varias funciones y no vamos a entrar en
mucho detalle de cómo es que esto está
involucrado en el proceso pero digamos
en cierto punto puede puede ser puede
brotar hacia fuera así que vamos a
dibujar dibujar esto un poco más grande
digamos tenemos aquí un acercamiento del
retículo endoplasmático verdad y digamos
que tiene como una protuberancia en
donde en el digamos ahí se encuentra
nuestra proteína verdad esto puede verse
después para un tiempo posterior digamos
de esta forma vamos a usar el mismo
color
forma
y aquí se encuentra de nuevo nuestra
proteína
y finalmente se verá más o menos algo
así
algo así con ya está digamos
protuberancia completamente separada del
retículo endoplasmático y de hecho
cuando tenemos digamos una proteína o
cualquier otro tipo de cosa que está
siendo transportada a través de una
célula con una pequeña digamos mínima en
paraná entonces a eso le conocemos como
una vesícula entonces esto que hemos
pintado aquí es una vesícula entonces
déjenme dibujar algunas vesículas en
nuestro dibujo original verdad aquí
tendríamos digamos una vesícula quizás
otra vesícula de estas tienen digamos
proteína dentro estas vesículas pueden
dirigirse a lo que conocemos como el
aparato de golgi que voy a dibujar
digamos con azul entonces este será
nuestro aparato de golgi que yo estoy
haciendo mi mejor esfuerzo por hacer un
dibujo que sea al menos entendible que
entonces este de aquí es nuestro aparato
de golgi
este es el aparato de golgi ya veces se
le conoce también como los cuerpos de
golf o el complejo de goji pero vamos a
llamarle aquí solo aparato de golgi y
esencialmente lo que ocurre aquí es el
proceso inverso verdad digamos estas
vesículas pueden unirse al aparato de
goya y vamos a poner una vesícula aquí
unida verdad con sus con su proteína
digamos que tiene contenida y una vez
que están dentro del aparato de golgi
esencialmente inician un proceso de
maduración verdad digamos para que estén
listas para ser transportadas hacia el
exterior de la célula o para ser
encajadas en la membrana celular verdad
entonces eso es lo que ocurre en el
aparato de golgi y una vez que ya han
terminado ese proceso de maduración muy
bien digamos ya tenemos una proteína
completamente bien manufacturada para lo
que tenga que realizar ya sea en él
porque puede ser que se pegue en la
membrana verdad déjenme hacerlo con el
mismo color
entonces ésta está digamos esta proteína
puede pegarse a la membrana celular y
ahora eso puede ser transportado digamos
ya sea hacia el exterior o puede ser
encajada dentro de la misma membrana